the information audio and visuals you
are about to see are intended to provide
details of an officer-involved shooting
which occurred on february 14 2022
at approximately 10 48 p.m in the
roadway of the 11 300 block of pensinger
road an investigation into the use of
force is being conducted to determine
whether the actions of the officers were
in compliance with law and department
policy
at the conclusion of the criminal
investigation all of the details will be
released to the kern county district
attorney for independent review
bakersfield police department officers
are equipped with body-worn cameras the
cameras do not capture everything the
officer saw or experienced and do not
encompass the entirety of the
investigation which includes witness
interviews forensic processing and
administrative review conclusions about
the officers actions with regard to law
and policy will not be made until the
investigation is complete and all facts
are known since the adoption of
body-worn cameras the bakersfield police
department has released footage of all
officer-involved shootings this footage
is being released to the community to
provide transparency this video may
contain strong language and graphic
images which may be disturbing to some
people viewer discretion is advised on
february 14th at 10 34 pm the
bakersfield police department received a
phone call from a subject who advised
they were armed with a knife and were
going to kill the next person they see
the caller advised they were at
pensinger road and windemere street
the subject's face and voice have been
obscured and or redacted throughout the
video as required by law because he is a
juvenile
do you have an emergency
[Applause]
officers arrived on scene and located
the caller at pensinger road and buena
vista road around 10 44 pm
the first body-worn camera footage is
from a witness officer and begins as
officers are in contact with the subject
i believe i have this subject he's on
the south side of the road
walking eastbound towards point of visit
hey bud
it's okay come here and talk to me
come here
growl for me
lay down on the ground
three i have the subject he's on the
property he's on the south side west
i need to
drop the knife
you have to
i'm gonna shoot you
running
traffic
we need to block off traffic at the
intersection of buena vista and
pennsylvania
hey bud come back here
[Music]
stay right there bud
he's got us drop it bud
you have to drop it
no one's going to hurt you
even if you want us to bud
we're going to get you help but we got
to do it a different way drop the knife
now
yes we do
you gotta drop it
we're gonna get you some help but you
gotta work with us
i need you to lay down the knife
lay down the night bud
[Music]
watch your backdrop
do you have less lethal or lethal
i need you to go less lethal if we can
stay there
drop the knife
you have to drop it so we can get you
some help
you have to drop it
we need northbound and southbound buena
vista shut down
at least a block on each direction
drop the knife
drop it
listen
i'm less lethal
it's lethal
but you have to drop it
your dad does not
less lethal first
we're not going to shoot you you
understand that i don't care how much
you ask
we're gonna we have to get you help a
different way
stay there
put the knife down now
we're not we're going to but you're
going to put the knife down
you have to
we are not going to shoot you you
understand that
we're going to get you help
but we have to do it a different way no
one wants to get hurt
you understand that right
you got the launcher
mally can you move around to my side
can you move around here
you're going to be fine you're going to
be fine bud
we're going no don't do it go ahead
don't do it
do not do it
less lethal longer and less lethal
nobody has guns
we're not going to do it
we need you to go our way we have the
right way to do this but you've got to
drop the knife
please drop it i'm asking you so we can
help you
drop the knife
the following body-worn camera footage
is from the involved officer who
discharged his firearm one time
[Applause]
so we can get him in custody
drop the knife
[Applause]
nobody has guns
we're not going to do it
we need you to go our way we have the
right way to do this but you've got to
drop the knife
please drop it i'm asking you so we can
help you
officers immediately secured the knife
and provided first aid to the juvenile
until relieved by responding medical aid
the juvenile was discharged from the
hospital the next day
this is an ongoing investigation the
bakersfield police department's use of
force policy including the deadly force
policy is available to the public at
www.bakersfieldpd.us